et pour parler de cette présence
américaine en afrique mériadec raffray
journaliste et membre de l'association
des journalistes de défense nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau mériadec raffray
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france pour commencer
pour recontextualiser que font
aujourd'hui les américains sur le
continent africain
alors les l'armée américaine en fait et
disséminés sur ce vaste continent
africain depuis djibouti jusqu'à ni
jusqu'à jusqu'au niger jusqu'à agadez au
nord de niamey la capitale du niger pour
faire simple ce sont aujourd'hui ces
deux bases permanentes opérationnelle la
première et la plus importante étant
djibouti la seconde de niamey est toute
récente
les américains ils font trois choses la
première plutôt dans l'est et dans le
sud de l'afrique de la région des grands
lacs
ils s'efforcent d'entraîner les armées
africaines
ils ont des contagions de marines qui
travaille avec l'armée ougandaise
l'armée somalienne enfin l'armée
somalienne ce qu'il ya dans mes
somalienne l'armée éthiopienne toutes
ses armes et qui sont confrontés à des
problématiques extrêmement difficile
avec la montée en puissance vous l'avais
dit dès des djihadistes dans cette
région une région de cette région de
l'est qui permet aux djihadistes de
communiquer entre la péninsule arabique
et la zone africaine qui fait partie de
leurs cibles
ça c'est la première chose donc j beauty
l'américain ils sont entre 4 et 6 milles
sur place et puis plus récemment ils ont
construit une énorme base au nord de
niamey la capitale du niger qu'à agadez
exactement où là on fait ils ont
localisé des drones qui les avaient
auparavant à niamey avec les français et
qui leur permet de rayonner depuis le
mali jusqu'à la libye à la fois pour
faire du renseignement mais également
pour cibler des des cibles à haute
valeur ajoutée comme comme ils disent
voilà donc à l'entraînement le
renseignement et la frappe de cible
qui sont liés en fait au combat
antiterroriste américain depuis 2001
cette lutte anti terroriste américaine
elle est efficace aujourd'hui sur le
continent a écouté les américains en
fait font une fonte deux choses la
première c'est l'élimination
chirurgicale de cible à haute valeur
ajoutée qui est dans la prolongation
d'un contrôleur de leur guerre contre
les terroristes de 2001
et là en particulier avec les drones
qu'ils ont à djibouti il frappe des
cibles d'al qaïda dans la péninsule
arabique les fameux la fameuse attaque
par al qaïda dans la péninsule arabique
notamment au yémen
ils font ça ils ciblent également des
shebab les les milices islamistes
somaliennes et là effectivement il
ils sont une à moins efficace parce
qu'ils ont des moyens technologiques qui
leur permettent de cibler d'aider des
gens qui sont difficilement qui se cache
dans la population ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est
l'entraînement écoutez d'entraînement
c'est il ya le verre à moitié plein ou
le verre à moitié vide
avant l'intervention française au mali
dans les années 2012 les américains sont
essayés à entraîner les maliens et ils
sont parti dépité en disant qu'ils
avaient mis un paquet de dollars dans le
sable pour pour rien finalement
donc c'est compliqué c'est les français
savent mieux faire ça que les américains
pour faire simple c'est ça marche mieux
et puis la troisième chose c'est le
renseignement et l'appui aux opérations
en particulier que mène la france dans
la bande saharo-sahélienne la bss et là
effectivement c'est un partenaire
important stratégiques un partenaire
efficace des armées françaises
car il apporte du renseignement et il
aide les français à comment dirais-je à
être permanent dans cette immense zone
qui correspond aujourd'hui opérationnels
qui correspond aujourd'hui la taille de
l'europe vous lisiez la france est
également présente à djibouti une grosse
base l'armée américaine aussi ils se
coordonnent bien france etats unis où il
ya d'autres intérêts finalement vous
avez raison de poser la question
djibouti en fait pourquoi djibouti à
djibouti faut savoir qui est aujourd'hui
à peu près une quarantaine de
représentations diplomatiques
internationales dans ce petit
confie-t-il d'état
se situe à un carrefour stratégique
entre une plaque tectonique entre la
péninsule arabique et l'afrique
vous êtes également à l'entrée de la mer
rouge qui conduit au au canal de suez
par où passe la majorité des
exportations de pétrole vers leurs vers
l'europe
vous êtes également à une zone de
connexion des câbles sous-marins qui
permettent à la internet de passer entre
l'europe et l'asie et vous êtes dans une
zone de carrefour en fait des milices
jihadistes on y trouve évidemment
depuis on y trouve donc les français
depuis des années les américains se
sentent en pousser un peu des coudes
pour faire de la place car ils ont su
remonter en puissance et en fait ils
marquent aussi à la culotte par des mois
cette expression mais c'est vraiment ça
ils marquent à la culotte
les russes les surtout les chinois
chinois qui sont arrivés en 2016 sur
place et qui aujourd'hui monte fortement
en puissance des chinois qui monte en
puissance militairement pour protéger
leurs intérêts économiques en afrique
alors effectivement en décembre 2008
c'est le conseiller à la sécurité john
bolton qui présentait à la stratégie
africaine à la maison de la maison
blanche deux objectifs contrer la menace
terroriste
on en a parlé ainsi que les conflits
violents mais aussi contre l'udc
contenir d'après les présence chinoise
ou russe vous venez d'en parler
aujourd'hui quel est l'objectif
prioritaire des américains en afrique
l'objectif prioritaire des américains
aujourd'hui c'est de ces la lutte
antiterroriste et à dire c'est le pro de
la prolongation ce que j'ai tout à
l'heure la prolongation de leur objectif
de 2001 ça c'est vraiment le la priorité
des priorités il faut savoir aujourd'hui
que par ailleurs le pentagone a le
comment dirais-je pilote un synthé renom
de deux programmes d'appuyer la sécurité
des états africains
je voulais un seul exemple en 2016 les
américains mettaient plus d'argent au
nigeria auprès des autorités nigérianes
qu'elle n'en mettais en irak c'est pour
vous donner une année état des lieux de
la réalité en fait de l'aide américaine
à ces états en 2016 parce que je n'ai
pas revu les chiffres depuis on parlait
à peu près d'une quarantaine de
yar de dollars dépensés dans ses plans
d'appui à la sécurité de ses états avec
des effets qui sont mitigés ils sont en
particulier en appui des états qui
luttent contre boko haram dans la région
du lac tchad et les effets sont quand
même pas évident les l'impact est pas
évident on peut aussi elle parlait de de
l'embuscade de tango tango qui a eu lieu
au niger en 2010 est où les forces
spéciales américaines ont perdu
plusieurs hommes ils ont dû leur survie
à l'intervention de l'armée française en
particulier les mirages de français qui
s'était bien gardé de tenir au courant
de leurs opérations il était parti un
peu comme la fleur au fusil et ils s'en
sont mordu les doigts
alors pour conclure le pentagone parle
lui d'une empreinte légère
qu'est ce qu'une empreinte légère pour
washington et à l'avenir
quelle est la stratégie sia cette
empreinte légère c'est uniquement de
base ce sont des forces spéciales qui
qui sont disséminés dans tous ses états
et que qui essayent monovalent de former
les forces spéciales des de ces pays est
en réalité
l'empreinte américaines en afrique
elle est presque symbolique elle n'est
en revanche pas symbolique pour les
français qui ont véritablement besoin de
l'appui américain pour mener cette
guerre contre les djihadistes dans la
bande saharo sahélienne mais cette
empreinte qui déjà légère s'inscrit dans
la volonté globale de l'administration
trump de de faire revenir leurs boys à
la maison cela passe depuis
l'afghanistan où ils négocient leur
retrait l'irak où ils ont négocié en
retrait et ça passe évidemment par le
fric
merci beaucoup mais avec raffray d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste spécialiste des
questions de défense